And I've got it figured out.
And then they grow like this.
It's a lot of contentious chat.
Is it a pip or is it a pop?
Because the pass is a little bit too narrow.
And they tee off on each other.
Why? Because they tend.
And they generally have good points.
If they're not receiving the pass
and they're not delivering the pass,
it's an issue.
Because in a game you're going to get it. You'll get one of those.
And that's what we don't want to coach.
This drill here, you're going to come through.
And this player here
starts here, he stands here
and the ball goes right here.
Point, point, point, point, point.
You hit this cone.
Sweep around.
And sweep around.
Okay?
And then you guys just come in
and you'll be closer, closer.
Okay?
What are a couple things that we can do
to